oh
i'm going back
um
right
great
okay today as promised we have the
premiere of dr ashisha our new white
house kovid
response coordinator uh in the briefing
room uh dr shaw will be talking about
two important pieces of work in our uh
we are working on with congress first
expanding access to life-saving coven 19
treatments and second our urgent need
for funding from congress he has time
just to take a very small number of
questions today but he will be come back
um
soon i'm sure so with that i will turn
it over to him and then we'll proceed
with him
good afternoon everybody
all right well it's great to be with all
of you a little um exciting and a little
scary with this crowd um so i want to
take a minute to talk about where we are
with the pendant we are i believe we are
at an inflection
one hand we know that va2 the sub
variant of omicron has become dominant
cases are rising across the country but
hospitalizations are at the lowest level
of the pandemic
right
and deaths are continuing to fall
we're down to about 300 deaths a day
still too many still too high
but doing so much for the better than we
have throughout much of this pandemic
despite all of that progress and i think
a lot of that is driven by the fact that
we've more than 200 million americans
vaccinated more than 100 million
americans uh boosted we know this virus
is tricky
we know that the risk of potential
surges even of a potential new variant
remains out there
the good news is we are at a point where
we have a lot more capabilities a lot
more tools to protect the american
people
testing
vaccines therapeutics
these are the sort of the pillars of how
we manage the rest of this pandemic
and that's why what i want to do is
spend some time talking to you about
those tools about our capabilities
what we're doing as an administration
and what we need from congress to
continue to protect the american people
so first i want to talk about pax lavid
the the therapy that has become
is becoming increasingly available to
the american people
for those of you who have not followed
this very closely pax of it became
authorized by the fda in late december
at that point there was just a very
limited supply of these bills
the clinical data suggests that it has
an enormously beneficial impact reduces
uh hospitalizations by more than 90
percent uh and uh is very very effective
at preventing severe disease
over the last few months the
administration has worked very hard with
pfizer
to increase the supply of paxlavid and
acquire
more and more doses for the american
people
and now our job is to make sure that
these doses are getting out there and
they're getting into uh into the hands
of patients who would benefit from them
so what are we doing and i want to talk
about four major things
um the first is we are opening up uh the
number of sites that can order directly
from the federal government uh
supplies the packs of it until until
this recent change uh the way pharmacies
got packs of it either you were a test
retreat site or you got it from your
state
but now we're opening up a federal
federal
pharmacy channel and what that means is
pharmacies can order directly from the
federal government
currently there are about 20 000 sites
in the united states that carry packs of
it we expect with this change that we
will very quickly get to 30 000 and
within the next couple of weeks i expect
us to get to about 40 000 sites
pax of it will be widely available
everywhere in america
that's going to help a lot
the second is the president announced
the test to treat effort that that we
have launched right now there are about
200 test retreat sites across the
country
and we are going to make a series of
efforts to expand the number of pesa
tree sites uh including
new federal initiatives that will allow
for us to build on other federal testing
sites to allow for uh for those who also
have a treatment component so if you
test positive you can go and get uh
treated with packs of it of course if
you are eligible uh and deemed so by by
a provider
third is we really are doubling down on
our communication and education efforts
with physicians and other prescribers uh
in the beginning when the when the when
packs of it first became available uh
the word on the street was these things
are now widely available you should
restrict it to the highest risk patients
too many physicians still have that
mindset
and what we need to do is to help
american physicians and nurse
practitioners and others who can
prescribe understand that we now have
plenty available and anybody who is
eligible anybody who's high risk should
be getting packs of it um
obviously base as long as they meet the
clinical criteria
and so that education campaign is going
to be really important and then last but
certainly not least is we're ramping up
our public awareness campaign so that
patients also understand that if they
test positive
they should consider going to a test to
treat site or reach out to their
physician but to get assessed for
whether pax of it would be useful for
them
those are all really critical steps that
i think are going to make an enormous
difference in getting more packs of it
out to the community to getting it out
to patients and with a very simple goal
right which is we want to lower the
severity of the disease that people get
if they get infected and we want to
lower hospitalizations we want to lower
deaths
paxlavid is a really important step in
our ability to fight this pandemic
treatments like these vaccines that we
have developed
these are the key essential tools that
we're going to need to get through the
rest of this pandemic
and that's the second part of the
conversation i want to have with all of
you
because all of this
requires funding from congress
so far congress has not stepped up to
provide the funds that are needed for
our most urgent needs
now i know they were off on a two-week
recess they are back
i'm looking forward to working with
congress we all are
to get
the funding needs of the american people
met on this uh on the issue of covid and
and kova treatments let me give you a
couple of concrete examples of what will
happen if we do not get the funding we
need
you may have heard if you've been
tracking this
that fda working with
modern and pfizer
looking at what the next generation of
vaccines may look like
and it is possible that we may get a
whole new generation of vaccines in the
fall or winter
that may be more effective and more
durable
none of those are going to be available
to the american people if we don't get
more funded
we are tracking new treatments that are
coming online
that are
as effective maybe even more effective
with fewer side effects
those treatments will not be available
to americans because other countries are
stepping up and making purchases for
those treatments
while we await funding from congress
the bottom line
is that none of us can predict with any
certainty where exactly this pandemic is
going what the virus is going to do next
all we can do is prepare
and that's what we need congress to do
is to help us prepare and be ready for
whatever eventuality comes let me make
one last point that i want to i think is
incredibly important
and that is that there are some people
in in this country who sometimes think
that we can take a domestic only
approach to a global pandemic
that's not a thing you can't do that if
we're gonna fight a global pandemic we
have to have a global approach
that means we need funding to ensure
that we're getting shots in arms around
the world the president and in his
leadership has enabled us to now have
plenty of vaccines for the world
but vaccines don't save lives right
vaccinations do we have got to finish
the job we've got to get the resources
we need to get shots in arms so we can
actually vaccinate the world and help
bring this pandemic to a close so those
are um those are the essential things
that are in front of us
this will require a partnership between
the administration and congress
i am confident that congress will
deliver for the american people and i
look forward to uh working with them on
that thank you
uh every time a high profile person like
the vice president catches cover for
attention on the infection uh for
americans following that news what
lesson should they draw
uh from that experience that somebody is
protected as her has caught cove yeah
good question um so i think if you take
a step back and look at uh the vice
president she is boosted actually twice
boosted right
we have a very very contagious variant
out there it is going to be hard to
ensure that no one gets coveted in
america that's not even a policy goal
the goal of our policies should be
obviously minimize infections whenever
possible but to make sure people don't
get seriously ill
the best ways of doing that are making
sure people are vaccinated and boosted
as the vice president is and making sure
we have plenty of therapeutics so
um you know so that is available as well
and that to me is the key lesson here is
she receiving any therapeutics since
we're on the topic of therapeutics you
know that's a conversation that she's
having with her physician i'm not her
physician i'm not privy to those
conversations so i don't know the answer
to that thank you dr john welcome to the
briefing by the way um
to your to your point that so many
americans can and will get this this
report that just came out today that 60
of americans have had it appears to have
had coveted
the president is getting ready to wrap
up his travel schedule the vice
president just caught it she's twice
boosted should americans be prepared for
a time when president biden gets this is
it just a matter of time that the
president could get copied
i wouldn't say it's just a matter of
time but of course it is possible that
the president like any other american
could get
the bottom line
is he is vaccinated and boosted he is
very well protected he's got very good
protocols around him to protect him from
getting infected but there is no 100
anything
and i think the key focus has got to be
we got to continue protecting the
president uh that's what the protocols
does around him are designed to do
um
yeah let me just let me leave it at that
yeah um
part of the congressional funding is to
potentially deal with the uninsured fund
that has run out of money
what does the uninsured fund not having
any money in it mean for
pax lopez or if if someone who's
uninsured gets covered right now what
does that mean for them
yeah so first of all pax love it itself
will be free right because
but they have to see someone who can
actually prescribe it for them and this
is one of the absolutely critical things
in a pandemic is that people need to be
able to access health care turns out
it's also critical not in a pandemic
right um but but it particularly in a
pandemic with an infectious it's really
important that people be able to access
healthcare services
get the care they need
it's good for them it's good for people
around them and so making sure uninsured
people have access
is absolutely critical so right now what
does that look like if someone gets
covered and they're uninsured
are they able to get treatment are they
able to get um tests or
does cbs just eat the cost how does that
work so i think right now because we
don't have the funding there's a little
bit of patchwork of what is happening
there are obviously places that serve
uninsured people community health
centers
others people can get care there are
still people are still going to
cvs and other places that still are
offering uh those services but that's
not a sustainable solution right so
right now we're in this kind of middle
ground where people are still getting
care but over time if congress continues
to not fund these urgent priorities it's
going to get harder and harder for
people to access care
too i apologize soon go ahead thank you
dr sean thank you so much for being here
just a couple of questions one can you
tell us
was president biden tested today and has
he tested negative we know the last time
i don't know i'm not involved in the
president's testing protocol so i i just
don't know the answer to the question
yesterday
okay thank you um on pax a little bit i
just want to be crystal clear because
you're
trying to expand access to it but you
still say if people meet the medical
requirements
does that mean that pax loads should
only be taken by people of a certain
agent who are immunocompromised
or that it should be taken by anyone who
has symptoms
no so so neither the fda has laid out a
very clear set of criteria for who
should get pacs of it
and very basically it's anybody who's at
high risk of developing complications
and the fda points to a cdc assessment
it's a it's a long list i can read it
all to you but of course age is
important presence of chronic diseases
but the bottom line is
that and what i i'm recommending to
family and friends is if you get covey
you should see a provider and make that
assessment with your provider um a lot
more people are eligible and ben would
benefit than i think people think very
quickly can you help us to understand
this moment that we are in because on
the one hand cases are going up
particularly on the east coast as you
have said hospitalization and deaths are
going down but is the country in the
midst of a search
what i would say is you know
we are going to see cases go up and go
down during this pandemic as we as we
head into the weeks months and years
ahead
um the key things that we need to be
following are our health care systems
getting stressed
are people ending up in the hospital
with severe illness obviously are people
dying at high rates those are the my
mind the most important metrics
and right now while infection numbers
are rising and of course we all want to
see infection numbers coming down
um the good news is because of the
extraordinary work of this
administration we've got americans much
better protected
and that means
uh that we're not seeing a huge bump in
hospitalizations the debts are still
declining obviously we want to continue
tracking those metrics
you're invited any time all right thank
you everybody
okay
a couple items at the top um today uh we
announced this morning that during
second chance month president biden made
a number of announcements focused on
second chances and re-entry which as
leaders on both sides of the aisle
recognize will help prevent and reduce
crime and strengthen our communities the
president announced 75 sentence
commutations and three full pardons all
of these individuals were convicted of
non-violent drug offenses and many have
been successfully serving their time on
home confinement he also announced more
than 20 major actions from a dozen
agencies to expand second chance
opportunities this includes a first of
its kind partnership between the
department of justice and the department
of labor to invest 145
million dollars in job training and
intensive re-entry in federal prisons it
also includes steps that will make more
incarcerated students eligible for pell
grants make it easier for those who are
incarcerated to enroll in medicare and
help formerly incarcerated veterans get
their benefits restored as we speak
susan rice dana remus and cedric
richmond are holding a virtual round
table with six formerly incarcerated
individuals to discuss the president's
first clemency announcement the new
re-entry policies and programs we
announced today
today's announcement mark import marks
important progress and we will continue
to review the president will continue to
review clemency petitions and deliver
reforms that advance equal justice and
public safety also wanted to note that
today uh secretary austin miassin hosted
a meeting of the ukraine defense
consultative group with ministers of
defense and chiefs of defense from more
than 40 countries at ramstein air air
base in germany the goal is to bring
together countries from around the world
for a series of meetings on the latest
ukraine defense needs to help ukraine
win the fight against russia's unjust
invasion and to help ukraine's defenses
for tomorrow's challenges as secretary
austin said it was an important and
constructive day agenda topics
included near-time near-term priorities
and longer-term planning the latest
battlefield assessments of the renewed
russian offensive establishing a
framework for prioritizing requirements
and logistics for resupply and
energizing the defense industrial base
to continue to the steady flow of
security assistance more than 30
countries have now stepped up to meet
our ukraine's urgent needs and have
committed more than 5 billion of
equipment including 3.7 billion from the
united states to support
ukraine's defenses we also wanted to
welcome
an important announcement by our german
allies today to send ukraine some 50
cheetah anti-aircraft systems we would
also highlight the british government's
announcement yesterday that it will
provide ukraine with additional
anti-aircraft capabilities and canada's
announcement that it will send ukraine
armored via calls i believe that's it
why don't we jump around to people who
didn't get questions initially go ahead
thanks jen a quick question on dr joe
talking about cases going up and the vp
testing positive um
can you talk a little bit about whether
the administration and society as a
whole perhaps have moved away a bit too
quickly from mitigation efforts such as
masking and is the administration
perhaps thinking about strengthening any
of those measures uh especially the ones
that we're losing well those decisions
and those recommendations are made by
the cdc and our public health officials
so
i don't have anything to preview for you
those are decisions that they make and
we obviously abide by that from here i'd
remind you that their recommendations
include
are based on what zone of the country
you live in uh right whether it is a
green zone yellow zone uh or a zone that
has a higher uh rate uh and they
continue to recommend masking on
transportation on you know that we and
we abide by that from here as well so
i'm i don't have any uh any changes on
that to preview but as as dr john noted
um our focus and as we noted when we
rolled out our 100-page plan continues
to be on tracking reducing
hospitalizations and deaths and we're
certainly aware that a very with a very
transmissible variant that there we
expected there could be a case increase
as we've seen over the last few weeks
with the a2 even in the regions that are
witnessing a surge i mean there is there
are no discussions that perhaps you can
talk about about you know what these
latest sort of um surgeons uh cases
could potentially well but masking
requirements uh change depending on what
uh the numbers look like in your
community right okay oh and and a quick
one on um the eu uh reuters is reporting
that the eu plans to declare that it is
entering a new uh supposed emergency
phase for kovit
given sort of the uptick in cases in the
u.s i'm wondering if you can talk a
little bit about that timing i mean is
that unusual
or do you think it is the right time for
the for countries around the world to be
headed uh towards that goal and if the
u.s is perhaps considering announcing
something similar uh going forward i
don't i think you mean an end of the
emergency um i don't have anything to
preview again those recommendations are
made by our public health and medical
experts so uh we rely on them for their
guidance on that and can i ask one on
ukraine sure um so that just earlier
today the announcement from germany on a
new package for heavier weapons uh that
obviously comes uh you know as russia
has said that such assistance would lead
to a nuclear war uh and it sort of
seemed like the u.s was brushing off
russia's uh recent nuclear threat and
i'm wondering if the administration to
what extent is it really taking this
latest threat seriously
well i think you heard some of our
national security officials make clear
there's no winning in nuclear war and
obviously our objective continues to be
to call and
reducing the rhetoric on taking the
rhetoric on that front down and i think
there have been some officials who have
abided by that uh but i would note that
the announcement by germany is in line
with announcements we've seen by a
number of european countries in
providing assistance they have never
before provided which is part of the
significance here so this is an
unprecedented change to provide lethal
aid to another country and that's the
significance here from germany but i'd
also note that norway uh provided uh
mistral anti-air missiles um that um
a number of countries have provided
types of assistance that they have never
done in the past and that really speaks
to this the unity of uh nato of european
countries and confronting uh what we see
as uh of course a horrific uh war in
ukraine launched by the russians
um is it possible that there might be
any updates to protocols code with
protocols within the white house in
light of vice president harris testing
positive for clothing
i would not expect that now
so there have been no discussions and
you don't expect that i think it's
important to remember that we have
stringent protocols here that go over
and above cdc recommendations even as it
relates to how long you stay at home uh
if you test positive um so individuals
who test positive for for here and i can
speak to this two times over um
there you go um
you uh don't return to work until you
have uh you have received a negative
test if that is before 10 days you are
still going to be masking that is beyond
what cdc protocols are there's a regular
testing cadence obviously the vice
president was tested this morning
because of that regular testing cadence
and for the rest of us anyone who's
going to be around the president to
travel with him to see him in the oval
office is tested that day and even if
you're not going to see him you're on a
regular testing cadence around here we
also take the step to socially distance
in meetings as frequently as we can
and also a number of us have chosen to
wear masks in meetings as well just as
an additional step in protocol so those
have been in place prior to today and we
will continue to abide by those moving
forward just on a different topic um
senator manchin
told reporters this morning that there
is not a build back better revival um he
said that social spending programs he
believes should go through a regular
order
not through the reconciliation process i
wondered if you could explain just from
the white house's perspective how you
all are thinking about reconciliation
versus regular order in terms of wanting
to get done some of the president's top
legislative priorities well you've heard
the president uh say many times that he
believes that a lot of the objectives he
has should be achievable uh through
bipartisan work together um it's not
democrats to you know democrats
shouldn't be able to own efforts to
reduce prescription drug costs or the
ability to negotiate the price of
prescription drugs nor should we be the
ones completely owning on our own
efforts to lower the cost of child care
health care those aren't democratic
ideals those should be those are those
are proposals that are broadly supported
by many americans across the country um
so we i we know that that senator
manchin has of course talked about his
efforts to pursue a bipartisan package
or bipartisan plan as it relates to
energy
costs and we're not going to prejudge
that effort but we're going to continue
to engage with a broad range of
democrats including of course senator
manchin about how to get the president's
agenda done is there anything you can
tell us about the president's schedule
today there wasn't anything uh publicly
announced is he in touch with uh members
of congress particularly since they're
coming back this week uh i expect he
will have a range of uh conversations
and engagements with members of congress
he also has a range of internal meetings
policy meetings planning meetings um
there's nothing where i can uh preview
on that from here but if uh if there's
more i can tell you after the briefing
i'm happy to do that um go ahead we've
got jen i'll start with something else
senator manchin said sure you're just
talking about him he said today we need
an immigration policy and title 42
should not be done away with until we
get an immigration policy or until the
cdc basically says we no longer have a
health crisis
what does it say about
the communication with
members of the president's own party
that senator manchin believes that title
42 is an immigration tool well i can't
speak to that necessarily i can tell you
that what it is and isn't it is not an
immigration tool it is a health
authority and one the cdc our health
experts of course uh do have authority
to make a decision about and they've
made the decision that the conditions no
longer exist to keep title 42 in place
we do agree with him absolutely there
should be an immigration policy and
there should be immigration reforms and
they are long overdue and we'd love to
work with him and any other members on
moving that forward does it concern you
that he's saying that title 42 should
not be done away with until there is an
immigration policy well that's just not
how it works um
obviously title 42 is uh the authority
was given to the cdc by congress they
made a decision if congress uh wants to
decide make any decisions about the next
steps for title 42 they can work
together on that but that is an
authority or a decision that have to but
would have to lay in the body that he
works in and then follow up on um what
dr jean said about sure to treat site
yeah
what is the administration doing to
expand those sites including converting
some testing sites to have
a treatment component what are the
challenges to that and do you have any
time frame for when you expect to ramp
up those facilities yeah it's a really
good question we shall probably have to
talk to dr john others from the health
care team about it um and next time
he'll take more questions i promise um
you're right there are some challenges
uh just like any aspect of applying uh
covid policy or covet treatment policies
or coveted um efforts to fight coveted
policies in that uh we have to educate a
large swatch of the public including
health care providers about how this
works or how it would work there's
continued efforts to do that but i'm
happy to check with them on expansion
plans or how that might work one more
quick one on vaccines for children under
five yeah the group protect their future
is just one of many groups that are
urging the fda to consider medera's
application
for an eua before june which is when
pfizer will also submit theirs
what is your response to these groups
who
um are concerned that appears concerned
that it appears the administration is
doing pfizer a favor
by waiting to consider both moderna and
pfizer at the same time when madonna's
data is already ready for review
by the end of this week
i'd really point you to the fda for
their decision-making process but i
would tell you that of course as a
parent of a child under five i'm eager
to have vaccines approved and available
and i want to make sure they go through
the proper protocols and process but uh
i would point you to the fda and uh
yeah
there are 18 000 petitions pending for
plumbing does the president plan to
increase his pace and consideration as
he
talks about possibly doing and also is
there
a consideration of a permanent permanent
clemency review process that would kind
of institutionalize this process
well first let me it's important to note
that the president has issued more
sentence commutations at this early
point in his presidency than any of the
la his last five predecessors at the
same point in their first terms so we
are far ahead of anyone any of the last
five presidents
that is because this is a priority to
the president
and as i noted uh when i at the top of
this briefing he feels this is uh second
chances are important and he believes is
absolutely a right uh step in our
justice system he is he's going to
continue to review uh clemency uh
petitions and that is going to be an
ongoing process that is of course run
through our council's office so it
doesn't stop here it will be ongoing and
there will be more in the future
a public health order it's not an
immigration order it's the cdc's
decision
uh but yesterday members of the
congressional hispanic caucus who met
with the president um relayed from what
he expressed in that meeting um and one
of them said that the president told the
group
that he was looking forward to lifting
title 42 describing it as an excuse to
keep people out of the country and
anti-immigrant
is the president
really wanting title 42 to go away
because it was a trump era policy
well the president has never felt that
title 42 was
a an effective immigration policy and he
talked about that during the campaign uh
but the authority has always rested in
the cdc to make that determination and
he left the cdc to make that
determination unlike his predecessor
about a range of decisions so the
president has never uh never uh made a
secret of the fact that he thinks
immigration reform is necessary and that
title 42 was never a replacement for
comprehensive immigration reform that
would put in place smarter security that
would ensure there was
an asylum processing system that worked
and that is something he would be eager
to work with anyone on to get done if
this conditions warranted it would the
white house want to see the cdc reimpose
title 42
in the instance that cases are up and
the metrics that they use to measure
that warrant that decision well the cdc
again has the authority to make a
determination about what the health
conditions uh warrant um so we will
leave it to them to make any decisions
recommendations um being out obviously
with the or
she's broken a lot of ties um for votes
and then we have senators i believe uh
wyden and murphy also out is there any
concern about ability to
get confirmations through this week
with her absence
well i would say there are also some
democrats who have announced that they
have also tested positive for covid um
you may be referring to the federal
reserve nominees or others um that is
something that members and leaders will
work through in congress we we are
confident we have the votes uh to get
them confirmed we're eager to have them
in place um but of course we need all
people all members there to do that and
i had one followed by dr jaws something
that he said earlier
we've talked about the administration
surging resources to the border um
including uh resources to vaccinate
migrants
and the last time i asked about this i
believe your answer was something along
the lines of we have enough funding and
supply to take care of
the 23 sites that dhs is going to be
running to get migrants vaccinated and
also take care of uninsured americans
but it sounded in his answer like that
might not be the case anymore so are we
in a place now where
there might be a choice where people
have to choose or the administration
have to choose between
supplying resources to migrants coming
across the border versus taking care of
uninsured americans i'm happy to check
on those resources jackie i would say
that
our broad concern about covid funding
is based on a couple of issues that he
talked about one of them is making sure
that we are ahead of the world on being
able to order ahead primarily a lot of
different treatments that uh will help
ensure that we have the best vaccines
the best boosters
enough supply once once
individuals under 50 are eligible
and certainly we want to keep all of our
programs
running across the country but
one more on the hunter biden reporting
we've seen come out
does the president still maintain that
he never spoke with his son about his
business dealings and given this
reporting on eric schwerin
also say that he had never spoken to
son's business partners
business feelings
uh he maintains uh his same statements
that he's made in the past i would say i
know you're referring to
waves records that were released more
than 10 years ago i really don't have
more detail or information on them i'd
note that there was a gap when waves
records were not released but i don't
have more information about visits from
more than 10 years ago good oh well let
me go around to people who haven't go
ahead oh thanks two questions on the war
on ukraine yeah respond on food aid yeah
does the administration have any idea of
how much money you'll need yet
for for global food aid given the the
shortfalls due to the war on ukraine
sure so um
let me first say that we are not
expecting a food shortage here at home
uh but we are acting to bolster food
security around the globe both
unilaterally and in conjunction with
allies and partners
one of the steps we're taking is we're
really conducting extensive diplomacy to
encourage all countries to refrain from
export restrictions and excessive
stockpiling obviously buying up or or
not exporting uh goods or products they
would normally do because it can
exacerbate supply chain chain challenges
and price inflation and and we want to
consider how to expand production of key
areas where we could see that happening
oil seeds and associated commodities
we're also working through multilateral
channels including the g7
to um to provide a range of funding to
the global agriculture and food security
uh program a 1.7 billion multilateral
financing mechanism is is part of what
we've done there that has helped the
world's poorest countries increase
investments in agriculture and food
security as we're anticipating global
shortages in some regions of the world
and through feed the future under
nutrition commitments we're also
committing over 11 billion dollars over
the next five years to address food
security threats and nutrition across
the globe in addition to the over four
billion dollars in humanitarian
assistance funding so we've taken a
number of steps funding mechanisms uh
you know multilateral financing
mechanisms also contributing um and
trying to use through diplomatic
channels uh you know efforts to to
prevent stockpiling and and and
decreasing of exports because we
anticipate uh it could be an issue and
we're already seeing that in some parts
of the world okay so no idea what the
global overall total would be for how
much footage
i don't think we have a prediction of
that at this point so what we're trying
to do is we're trying to get ahead of
what we anticipate being a shortage or
an impact in some parts of the world and
working through
multilateral mechanisms to help address
that even as we don't foresee it being a
food shortage issue here natural gas
russia says it's going to cut off poland
starting tomorrow which is a pretty big
escalation by russia is the
administration concerned that gazprom
might cut off other european nations um
from to get natural gas supplies and is
the u.s would do anything to help poland
make up for sure let me check and see if
there's anything specific to poland what
i can tell you we've talked about the
little bit a little bit in here before
is that for the last several months and
even prior to the invasion we have been
working to increase natural gas supply
and options to european countries that
have been reliant on
russia for natural gas supply in
anticipation of the possibility of this
happening or a decrease in what they're
providing so some of that has been
asking some countries in asia who have
excess uh supply to provide that to
europe we've done that in some cases um
and it's been an ongoing effort but i
can see if there's anything specific for
poland given this recent announcement go
ahead
thank you um two questions on the
pardons um there were pardons and
communications there were three pardons
two of them were for non-violent drug
offenses can you talk at all about sort
of what it was about those two cases
that stuck out to the president given
that there are a lot of people who
applied for pardons that have similar
circumstances and and didn't receive a
partner today is there anything about
those two that are emblematic of
anything that is honest sure well i
think many of you reported on these
cases and the compelling nature of their
personal stories but i would note that
his focus at this point in time was on
individuals who had less than four years
to serve
a number of them a good percentage of
them and i can find the exact number in
here are also already under home
confinement um currently
and this is again just the first step
and he will continue to review
clemency
requests and petitions over the course
of his presidency and certainly in the
coming months
in addition there's a large backlog of
people who've applied for pardons and
commutations and given that was there
any denials in this first wave is he
denying anybody a pardon or connotation
it's a good question i'm happy to check
with our council's office and see or if
it was just this was the first round
that was granted through the process
going through
um
two questions jen um first following up
on dr shaw he said that he talked about
global funding yeah pandemic yeah
republicans have said that they want
that money offset so has the
administration does the administration
intend to propose
ways to offset that five billion dollars
or do you think that's a lost cause and
second um the president has a number of
crowded events coming up on his calendar
a couple of funerals the white house
correspondents dinner and in light of
the vice president's diagnosis can you
talk about the calculations
that the president is making and
thinking about
whether to attend these kinds of events
and also whether he has any special
obligation as president to keep himself
sure uh well in the first question
cheryl we're not quite there yet i mean
we have requested 22.5 in the past and
obviously that is where our emergency
request will be moving forward for the
short-term needs that we have
this has been passed past coveted
funding as you well know has been passed
through emergency authorities where it
hasn't uh been offset um and we
certainly think that's reasonable but
we're at such the early stage of this
process having not even sent it up to
the hill yet we're gonna have to have
all of those conversations about how to
move it forward uh on the second piece
uh what i will tell you is that
we make risk assessments here just like
every american does
and as it relates to of course keeping
the president safe and all of us safe
now naturally he has access to the best
health care in the world he
consults closely with his doctor we take
a range of steps i i noted in response
to mj's question earlier that go beyond
uh even most workplaces in the country
in terms of required testing for those
who who will be around him social
distancing obviously he has his own
regular testing cadence but we do make
assessments and and he makes assessments
about uh when he feels it's important
for him to uh attend or participate in
an event um and you mentioned two of
them obviously this weekend he'll be
attending the white house correspondents
dinner it's an opportunity to honor the
work of all of you and many of your
colleagues
and to
and to talk about the importance of
journalism in the world that's an event
he's attended many times in the past and
he made a decision through consultations
that it was an event he could attend and
wanted to attend again uh and obviously
uh former vice president mondelez
someone he had
an important personal relationship with
he wanted to attend his memorial service
obviously these discussions are always
done through our scheduling team the
covid team to make sure we're taking
every step possible but just like many
americans
he makes risk assessments and i would
say the last piece which you didn't ask
about but you know people asked about in
here as well he's been traveling the
country more recently um you know he was
traveling three days last week and
we and of course uh coordination with
the president made a decision that was
vitally important uh to him to his
presidency to the american people uh and
certainly uh that's one of the reasons
we want to be very clear that it is
possible he could test positive for
kovid um that uh just like any american
even though he's double boosted that is
possible um and uh you know we we will
of course uh be very transparent about
that if that were to take place
yes i do go ahead yeah yeah and then
i'll try to go to the back go ahead
uh multiple
outlets uh cbs washington post reported
today that uh in yesterday's meetings
with meeting with the congressional uh
hispanic hospice the president biden
signaled
that he was prepared to use executive
authority to cancel
student debt in the coming months can
you confirm that this was something
relayed
to them by the president and why uh what
exactly is the president considered
doing when it comes to to student aid
debt sure well let me use this
opportunity to reiterate that nobody has
paid a sing a penny in student loan
federal student loans since the
president took office and what we've
said from here is that and what he
reiterated is that uh he will make a
decision uh before there's an end to
that pause right now it's been extended
through august and we have talked about
how we are looking at and he is looking
at other executive authority uh options
he has uh to bring relief to uh people
who have student loans um so that's what
he conveyed during the meeting
using executive action though i mean is
that something a step now that the
president is seriously looking at well
we've talked about that in the past um
so he's continuing to look at it
going back to vice president harris
positive test for covet is the white
house uh trying to determine exactly uh
where and when she would have been
exposed to covet as the assumption that
it was during her trip uh to california
last week in his the white house
uh in the vice president's office doing
any effort to contract trace in order to
maybe notify people during that lengthy
trip to who she might have ran into just
like um and for anyone who tests
positive around here um we do contact
tracing uh so that people are aware if
they should take additional measures or
precautions whether it's masking or
getting additional pcr tests and we're
certainly doing that
in light of the vice president's
positive test as well go ahead thanks
john i wanted to ask if the white house
had any reaction to that court case that
uh put the temporary block on title 42
being revealed
and then i have a follow-up question
about vice president paris sure well
things sometimes happen when i'm out
here but when i before i came out here
they had uh only done kind of the verbal
briefing as of last night so i'm not
sure if there's even a new development
or that okay so what i will tell you is
that department of justice will
need to review um kind of any um any
rulings before commenting and that was
verbal there'll be something more formal
as our as our expectation uh and they
would uh discuss any next legal steps or
interpretation of the ruling so we'll
leave that to them and we'll see if more
comes out today
president harris you know the last time
she was tested prior to this morning and
is there any uh therapeutics that she's
taking
so she's on a regular testing protocol
just like the president i can certainly
check and see um that information um and
then as dr zha referenced she would
consult with her doctor on any
treatments
go ahead nadia thank you on foreign
policy a national security adviser jake
sullivan is supposed to meet with this
israeli counterpart tomorrow um
the israelis have made it publicly known
that this disagreement with the white
house with the iran and going back to
the negotiation can you update us first
of all why is coming here what's on the
agenda and i have another question sure
um will they uh consult regularly i
would say as you know the president uh
had a fruitful conversation with israeli
prime minister bennett just a couple of
days ago um and so this is a follow-up
to that conversation and they'll discuss
a range of regional and global security
uh issues um and part of that you know
the president when he spoke with prime
minister bennett they also talked about
a range of global and regional issues
and prime minister bennett extended an
invitation for him to visit israel which
he accepted and will do we don't have a
date yet to announce they also talked
about um the iran nuclear deal
negotiations which we uh we keep the
israelis uh briefed regularly on so uh
certainly that could be a part of this
conversation as well also secretary
blanken this morning testified at the uh
senate foreign relations committee he
said that breakout time for iran is
weeks away uh he blamed the previous
administration from withdrawing from the
deal does this worry the white house
that we're talking about two weeks that
iran could actually develop a nuclear
weapon
yes it definitely worries us um i would
say that if we go back you know under
the um under the iran nuclear deal
iran's nuclear program was tightly
constrained and monitored by
international inspectors and since the
trump administration seized u.s
participation in the deal iran has
rapidly accelerated its nuclear program
and reduced cooperation with
international inspectors uh in
non-performance of iran nuclear deal
commitments so as you noted what
secretary blanken said during his
testimony this morning was that their
breakout period is down from about a
year which is what we knew it was during
the deal to just a few weeks or less
and certainly that is a direct impact of
pulling out of the nuclear deal making
us less safe giving us less visibility
and it's one of the reasons we
pursued a diplomatic path again when the
president uh took office
okay april last one okay label last one
two questions sure really fast
when it comes tomorrow's a new day
go ahead april
hello this is april i'm sorry um jen the
two questions
on haiti uh what are the conversations
can you shed light on the conversations
about the
haitian
uh immigration issue
as title 42 is set to end
next month and also
as the vice president has tested
positive for posing and it is in the
realm of possibility as the president is
traveling if he gets coveted in this
moment what is the line of succession if
both of them are very ill with covet at
this point
well technically the speaker of the
house is the third in line so
there you go no i'm just confirming that
for you um it is true
as we've noted many times it is possible
the president could test positive we
will be very transparent with you if
that were to happen he has access to the
best health care in the uh in the world
and we
believe because of all the precautions
and steps we have taken that he would be
able to continue his duties as the vice
president is as well as vice president
so i don't have any prediction of that
at this point in time in terms of your
first question on haiti tell me a little
bit more about what you mean the way i
understand um
that there has been a conversation or
various conversations to include um at
the u.n here about how do you handle the
patient migrant issue when patients are
being sent back and then you're bringing
other refugees in and i'm hearing that
there are conversations around the
administration about how to handle one's
type of title 42 ends
i would have to dig into this a little
bit deeper i mean as you know there's
tps right um that has been granted for a
period of time so that is a something
that uh haitians who have been here at a
certain from a certain point in time
have access to um beyond that
our focus though is of course on uh
continuing to be the largest provider of
aid and assistance to haiti um ensuring
we can take steps there to lead in the
world encouraging other countries in the
world to take steps as well um beyond
that uh maybe we can talk after the
briefing and i can find out a little bit
more about you mean i will go to the
back tomorrow first thing thank you so
much
you